Wayne cousins is a wrong pure and simple
he should never have been in the Police
Service part of this is all to do and
it's not just the police it's the
Judiciary the presis service the
national health is the age of austerity
foed Upon Us by David Cameron and George
Osborne and the worst Home Secretary in
my view in my lifetime Theresa May
they've just cut cut cut I remember back
back in the day there was police
stations all over
London we were taught in training school
that police station is a place of
safety well there aren't any anymore if
you're a female late at night you
haven't got a taxi to get home whatever
these to turn up at police
stations and a lot of the time a police
officer would drive them home or they
call a taxi to the police station or
they could sit there till a member of
their family came to collect them that's
all gone